Wooo we are live and I brought a pet peeve that has been living in my chest since Lisbon. Welcome back to The Office 360 Unfiltered. I am Alex. Today is about keys. Who holds them. Agencies love to build your pretty site and then keep the repo, the fonts, the Figma, the domain logins, the whole house. You paid for a home. You got a lease with a smile on it. Come on. Come on!
Ha, I have seen the email. I have the screenshots. Sorry, we cannot export that, it is in our proprietary theme. Sorry, the designer owns the Figma. Sorry, hosting is in our account and the password is a secret. We can make the change next sprint. That is not partnership. That is a hostage note with a status meeting attached. At The Office 360 you own every line of code. Every asset. Period. No cute exceptions.
Let me translate that into boring, beautiful truth. Ownership means the Git repo is in your organization. The domain is in your registrar. The DNS is in your account. The design files are in your Drive. The CMS, the keys, the analytics. When we are done, you could fire us tomorrow and the site still belongs to you. That is the test. If you cannot leave, you do not own it. You are renting a smile.
And it gets funnier, in the sad way. A publisher we audited could not change a book cover without opening a ticket. A church could not update Sunday time because the special theme broke if anyone but the agency touched it. A school calendar was locked behind a plugin license that expired, and the agency wanted a retainer to renew it. You already paid to build the thing. Now you pay to knock on your own door.
Four seniors. Lisbon to New York. We hand you the keys because we do not make money trapping you. Fixed scope. Fixed price. You know the number before we write a line. Automated QA so we are not babysitting. No junior maze. No proprietary lock. When the invoice is paid, the house is yours. That is not a slogan. That is the contract. And if a fifty person deck impressed you while they kept the passwords, you already know how this story ends.
And look, this is the same joke in a bottle, which is why this episode is sponsored by Klear. Klear with a K. Traditional protein is thick and secret and sits in your stomach like a proprietary theme. Klear is clear whey isolate. You can literally see it. Twenty grams of protein, zero sugar, zero lactose, about ninety calories. We earn a commission if you use our code. That keeps this live show on the air, and I would rather tell you that than hide it.
Two cities, long days, I am not slamming gym sludge between calls. Strawberry watermelon is the one. Wild blue raspberry if you want the tang. One scoop, twelve ounces of water, shake it, let it settle a minute, drink it like a sports drink. Exclusive twenty percent off, code MARKETPL. klearprotein.com/discount/MARKETPL. Use that link, not a random one. Same rule as the repo. Use the keys that are actually yours.
Homework, and I want you to actually do it. Email your current shop today. Ask for the repo. Ask for the design files. Ask for the domain logins, the host, the analytics. If they stall, if they say it is complicated, if they say you need a retainer first, you already have your answer. Then call us. theoffice360.com. Code STUDIO50. Fifty percent off the studio tiers. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com. Four people. You own the work.
I love this show because it is the same philosophy twice. Don't rent your stack. Don't rent your fuel. Don't swallow the heavy version just because the industry printed a brochure. Authors, schools, publishers, churches, if your site needs a priest and a project manager every Sunday, it is not your people. It is the lock on the door. We build so a parent on a bus can find pickup time. So a member can give in two taps. Then we hand you the keys and we get out of the hallway.
Own the site. Own the fuel. If your protein still tastes like chalk, Klear, klearprotein.com, code MARKETPL, twenty percent off. If your homepage is pretty and nobody can use it, you know where we live. I'm Morgan, he's Alex, this was The Office 360 Unfiltered, sponsored in part by Klear. We love you. Bye!